[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale la crise
des migrants
après l'optimisme affiché est de fin de
semaine les divergences entre pays
européens ont fait surface dans quel
pays placé les nouveaux centres
d'accueil de migrants à l'intérieur des
frontières européennes la france ne veut
pas l'italie ferme ses portes pour l'été
et le principe du volontariat laisse peu
d'espoir à l'ouverture de centres dans
un dans une majorité de pays réticents
l'europe at elle manqué l'une de ses
dernières chances de garder sa cohésion
un flou d'autant plus inquiétant que
l'allemagne a tre premier moteur de
l'europe est miné par une grave crise
politique interne
angela merkel a sauvé de justesse son
alliance avec la ses sous et son
improbable cohabitation avec son très
conservateur ministre de l'intérieur la
chancelière a renoncé à sa politique
migratoire généreuse à sous la pression
de la droite bavaroise on veut en
débattre avec nos invités sylvie
guillaume bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente du parlement européen députée
européenne du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates merci d'être venus yannick
jadot
bonjour vous êtes député européen du
groupe des verts merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation enfin nicolas bay
bonjour bonjour vous êtes co président
du groupe europe des nations et les
libertés est ici au parlement européen
député européen a donc et secrétaire
général du rassemblement national le
nouveau nom du front national merci
d'être venu mais d'abord les images on
décrypte ce conseil européen spécial
migrants décryptage signé elsa monde à
gaza
[Musique]
m
les 4h30 à bruxelles au bout de neuf
heures d'âpres négociations le président
du conseil européen donald tusk annonce
sur twitter
les 28 dirigeants de l'union européenne
se sont accordés sur les conclusions du
sommet européen y compris la migration
soulagement des chefs d'état européens
c'est pour la france une bonne nouvelle
c'est d'abord le fruit d'un travail
conjoint etc la coopération européenne
qui l'a emportée
même l'italie au coeur du dossier des
migrants semble satisfait de ce conseil
européen sort une europe sous le
responsable et plus solidaire
l'italie n'est plus seul un accord
négocié au forceps qui permettent à
l'europe de sauver les apparences mais
pour combien de temps quelques heures
seulement après la signature de l'accord
l'unité se fissure les 28
contactée la création de centres
contrôle et de migrants dans l'union
européenne
oui mais où à en france pour emmanuel
macron pour ce qui est des centres en
europe
c'est sur une base volontaire
premièrement et dans les pays qui sont
les pays de premier accueil les pays de
premier arrivé est donc l'italie
inadmissible pour le chef du
gouvernement transalpin macron était
fatigué je le contredit mais nous avons
tous fini en retard à cinq heures du
matin
l'article 6 ne mentionne pas des pays de
premières entrée ou des pays secondaires
pas plus que l'article 12
seule l'espagne de pedro sanchez et la
grèce d' alexis tsipras ce serait prête
à accueillir de tels sans la fragilité
de l'accord tient en fait en un mot le
volontariat
aucune contrainte n'est fait au pays ni
pour accepter la répartition des
migrants ni pour abriter des centres
d'accueil c'est alors une victoire pour
un groupe de pays que l'on nomme le
groupe devise grade la hongrie la
pologne la république tchèque ou encore
la slovaquie des pays d'europe de l'est
hostile à l'accueil des migrants est
farouchement opposé à l'instauration de
quotas
autre proposition de ce sommet des 28 la
création de plateformes de débarquement
hors de l'union européenne
mais là encore il faudra convaincre des
pays d'afrique du nord ont déjà signifié
leur refus
des décisions sur la base du volontariat
mais peu de volontaires
voici donc ce que les 28 ont réussi à
négocier pour ne pas perdre la face
cet été d'autres aquarius pourrait à
nouveau mettre en lumière l'incapacité
des membres de l'union européenne 1 voir
une politique migratoire commune
[Musique]
voilà question toute simple est ce qu'il
vous satisfait ce compromis trouvé au
sommet de bruxelles non mais si l'idée
était de donner le change avec une sorte
de solution politique pour les opinions
publiques mais aussi pour en termes de
cohésion entre quelques états à la
pointe de la réflexion sur le sujet oui
c'était une sorte de règlement politique
de la faire mais en réalité rien n'est
réglé et présenter les choses telles que
cela était dans votre reportage sur la
question du volontariat et le bon angle
c'est à dire que pour l'instant il va
falloir déterminer pourquoi
absolument rien qu'il s'agisse des pays
sources d'immigration qu'il s'agisse des
pays qui sont des pays de premières
entrée et qu'il s'agisse de la
répartition solidaire dans lesquels on
doit se trouver
rien n'est réglé donc la crise politique
est suspendue notamment avec la
situation en allemagne mais le reste
reste complètement en chantier yannick
jadot vous acquiescez rien n'est réglé
ascom est pour rien un sommet pour rien
l'europe en tout cas les dirigeants
européens continuent à mettre la tête
dans le sable on à la fois une réalité
il faut dire la vérité c'est que on a
beaucoup moins de réfugiés cette année
que les années précédentes la deuxième
vérité c'est que les l'italie
particulièrement ces derniers mois a
accueilli beaucoup de réfugiés et que
l'europe les autres pays européens n'ont
pas été solidaires on a laissé
d'utilisation on a nourri la bête c'est
fini on a alimenté un gouvernement qui
d'extrême droite a été élu par les
citoyens italiens parce que justement on
n'a pas été solidaires et la
responsabilité aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
des dirigeants la hauteur des enjeux et
il va falloir à un moment donné
accueilli intégré en responsabilité en
solidarité
les réfugiés qui sont aujourd'hui
massivement en italie en grèce ou
ailleurs et que de ce point de vue là on
n'a rien résolu
on l'a vu dans le reportage nicolas bay
le président du conseil italien giuseppe
comté s'est exclamé à la sortie du
conseil
l'italie n'est plus seul les 28 ont pris
en compte la situation dénoncée par
l'italie je crois que c'est un grand
classique d'un sommet européen comme
celui-là d'avoir tout le monde qu'elle a
faim dit qu'il a gagné qu'il a obte fait
obtenu satisfaction
la réalité quand on regarde de plus près
ce qui s'est passé et le texte de
compromis qui en a résulté c'est que il
ya deux grands perdants c'est angela
merkel emmanuel macron qui finalement
défendez avec la commission européenne
depuis des années l'idée qu'il faut
répartir les migrants de manière
autoritaire avec des quotas qu' il faut
pas réellement protéger les frontières
extérieures
tout ça s'est totalement effondré et ce
qu'ils regagnaient si les pays du groupe
de visegrad ce que vous dites d'ailleurs
dans votre reportage la hongrie la
slovaquie la pologne est aussi
évidemment en première ligne l'italie
avec matteo salvini qui est en première
ligne pour dire maintenant ça suffit
1 on va protéger les frontières
extérieures de il n'y a pas de quota de
migrants automatiquement est parti et on
arrête la logique qui veut qu'on fasse
venir des clandestins c'est pas des
réfugiés pour l'immense majorité d'entre
eux ne fut pas la guerre pour l'immense
majorité ils viennent pour des raisons
économiques
il faut évidemment finir avec cette
logique là c'est à dire on
arrête de les faire venir pour traiter
ensuite la demande d'asile sur le
continent européen
alors même qu ensuite ne sont jamais
expulsé souvent total sont régularisés
plus naturalisés on traite le problème
en amont c'est beaucoup plus juste
beaucoup plus humain parce que ça évite
qu'ils prennent des risques qu'ils
engraissent les mafias les passeurs et
qui meurt en méditerranée il faut
traiter dans les pays d'émigration à la
périphérie immédiate des péris des pays
d'émigration sur le continent africain
avec des corridors humanitaires et c'est
de là qu'il faut de la télé c'est quand
même flou h précises à propos des
centres d'accueil à l'extérieur de
l'union européenne le maroc l'algérie la
tunisie ne veulent pas en construire ne
veulent pas en entendre parler
mais surtout ce dont pas monsieur b c
notamment la façon ça se gère en libye
la façon ça se gère en libye c'est
simple ce sont des bandes armées qui
gère les réfugiés dans le désert
alors parfois ils le font avec le
financement européen ce qui est
absolument indigne de l'europe mais ils
le font dans les viols dans les
violences dans les meurtres
est ce que c'est ça l'europe des valeurs
et des principes et moi je suis presque
étonné c'est que d'une certaine façon
vous défendez salvini et vous défendez
organes salvini dit quoi il dit il faut
la solidarité européenne qu'est ce qui
dit hors ban aucune solidarité
européenne donc on peut pas dire le tout
et son contraire aujourd'hui il ya assez
peu de réfugiés qui arrivent de la crise
de 2015 elle est derrière nous
certains pays le long assumer bravo 2015
2016 1 million qui arrivent sur les
côtes européennes l'allemagne
aujourd'hui quatorze mille en italie
l'allemagne a quasiment mis les droits
sur chaque réfugié
bravo aux allemands aujourd'hui si c'est
chacun chez soi c'est les réfugiés pas
chez moi il n'y a pas de solution
on peut essayer de s'enfermer on peut
mettre des frontières
à partir du moment où vous avez des gens
qui ont voyagé des mois et des mois
qu'on survit depuis des mois et des mois
ils vont essayer de venir et ils peuvent
légitimement accéder au statut de
réfugiés en europe
donc on regarde la réalité et puis on ne
traite pas parce que ça a été dit ça
n'est plus une crise des réfugiés c'est
une crise politique européenne et pour
résoudre la crise politique européenne
il
redonner de l'espoir dans une solidarité
européenne
au delà de la question des réfugiés et
des migrants ça veut dire investir
investir pour créer de l'emploi pour nos
jeunes investir pour retrouver le sens
de la solidarité et d'une perspective
commune en europe c'est la meilleure
façon c'est d'être ouvert au problème
sur une vidéo que vous en parliez à ce
que le problème ce n'est pas que
l'europe n'a pas de vision très claire
des enjeux en termes migratoire vision
partagée à court moyen long terme de ces
gens de là on est toujours en réaction
il est clair que quand on regarde la la
façon dont les gouvernements les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement réagisse on a
vraiment une vision court termiste des
choses qui s'opposent d'une certaine
manière et je vais vous donner un
exemple à ce que le parlement essaye de
faire dans la durée
mais moi j'adore ce genre de discussion
ou d'un seul coup pour monsieur b les
autres c'est l'enfer il faut surtout
faire repousser au maximum et le yaka
fokon et puis une vision qui est certes
juste de la solidarité
mais à un moment donné faut aussi avoir
des éléments pragmatiques je vous donne
un exemple comme je vous l'aï été
engagée prenez la question du règlement
dublin qui est quand même la clé de
voûte concernant l'asie qui part du
principe que tous les systèmes d'asile
sont soldes sont similaires dans l'union
ce qui est évidemment pas juste et donc
qui génère quelques fois des réactions y
compris chez les ministres de
l'intérieur français les formes de
benchmarking qui fait qu'ils seraient
faits par l'événement de rappel dublin
c'est je demande l'asile au premier pays
non non c'est le pays qui accueille le
premier comprendre est la demande est
forte la demande
on a au parlement européen analyser ce
phénomène est fait de proposition en
considérant que le seul critère de
l'entrée sur le territoire ne valait
rien puisque de toute façon les systèmes
ne sont pas les mêmes donc on a élaboré
quelque chose qui est au point
depuis plus d'un an maintenant qu'on a
réussi à faire voter au plomb du
parlement européen dans une assemblée
qui est très diverse évidemment donc
mais majoritairement on est arrivé nous
sommes parvenus à nous mettre d'accord
depuis un an le conseil refuse d'aborder
cette question et rejette jusqu'après
les élections européennes de 2019
l'examen de cette solution là je suis
désolé mais quand on est
pragmatique et qu'on regarde les
situations je crois qu'on est en
situation d'être pédagogique vis-à-vis
de l'opinion publique qui est très
perturbé par l'hystérisation qui est de
mise
s'agissant des questions de migration et
d'asile et là on a la possibilité d'être
clair précis ordonné de contrôler les
choses c'est dommage que les états
membres ne se saisissent pas de ça vous
êtes d'accord il n'y a pas de crise
migratoire mais une crise politique
nommée ya évidemment une crise
migratoire pourquoi parce que même s'il
ya un peu moins de deux clandestins qui
arrivent en europe en 2010 par rapport à
2010 l'immense majorité sont pas des
réfugiés
en réalité on a dépassé depuis longtemps
le seuil de saturation et c'est
évidemment tout me plaît maman et la
vérité c'est que il y en a - un peu -
italie cette exonération par notamment
parce que l'italie a depuis des mois
pris l'initiative de rétablir les liens
avec le régime libyen
même s'il est très bien les gilets quel
régime il ya une idéologie qui sert
d'interlocuteur pas dur mais ça c'est à
toi sarkozy qui a déstabilisé la libye
ensuite il ya d'autres routes les routes
secondaires les balkans l'espagne et
n'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus
de me rentrer dedans qui arrivent mais
d'une manière générale pour répondre à
sylvie guillaume sur le lieu sur dublin
4 la réforme dublin 4 visait à permettre
aux migrants qui arrivent de s'installer
dans quatre pays au choix de merde le
temps de traiter leurs demandes d'asile
bon évidemment ils vont aller là où les
avantages sociaux ou les prestations de
la logique sanekh général de faire venir
une immigration supplémentaires fort
aujourd'hui le message de tous les
peuples avant tout les élections sans
exception hongrie en autriche en italie
et bien c'est dire on ne peut plus
accueillir de migrants et donc il s'agit
pas de dire on en a un peu moins l'année
cette année que l'année dernière
aujourd'hui on a eu tellement qu'ils
sont arrivés en gala merkel on a fait
venir un million cinq cent mille en
allemagne en fait le résultat c'est
qu'elle est évidemment très fragilisée
par ce que les allemands on va en parler
lui reproche évidemment cette politique
totalement irresponsable et quand on
entre en sciant 6 millions de chômeurs
en fait les mains d'erdogan des bandes
armées libyennes laissé libre sous
couvert de traces et nous met en
chantage en permanence en disant si vous
n'allez pas y compris dans le soutien de
nos régimes de plus en plus autoritaire
nous allons lâcher il faudra vérifier de
verser 6 milliards d'euros à la turquie
pour prétendument contrôler les flux
migratoires ce qu'elle fait de façon
très imparfaite et puis le trafic
d'êtres humains à savoir répondre à ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure le trafic
d'êtres humains en libye
c'est évidemment un scandale mais ce qui
est ce qui alimente ce trafic
c'est évidemment la perspective pour les
mafias les passeurs avec souvent la
complicité des ong au pouvoir faire
passer les migrants en méditerranée ont
ceci permet une protection des
frontières extérieures
eh bien ce sont l'histoire marché aux
esclaves et c'est le trafic d'être
humain existera de l'humanité quand il
ya du malheur quand il ya la guerre
quand vous prenez des bombes chimiques
moment donné à un moment donné vous
fuyez quand y'a le des règlements et que
les hyades le gamin à bitam il n'y a pas
un migrant sur 100000 qui a eu des
attaques chimiques 21 condé n'importe
quoi quand on sait qu'une amie mais
quand les paroles on le reconnaît leur
reconnais que c'est pas la balle mes
vieux des ministres
on va poursuivre on va pour que les gens
saison contraints de quitter leur maison
ils le font jamais par plaisir
ils le font certainement pas ils
voyagent pas un an dans le désert en
pensant aux allocations sociales enfants
c'est totalement débile de dire ça
simplement quand ils sont dans cette
situation là il faut se donner les
moyens de les accueillir
il faut se donner les moyens de voter
après devant les conditionner les aides
financières d'accord pour considérer que
plus de 80% des mouvements de
populations ne se font pas vers l'europe
il se fond dans le locaux régional
quelques fois à l'intérieur du pays même
où dans la région avoisinante et jamais
vers l'europe
donc faut arrive à jamais dans une
partie importante vers l'europe et les
90 par exemple les bateaux
énorme réalisé sur maps le droit moi je
m'en tiens à la souhaite une oeuvre à la
fois dans le locaux régional et pas en
sud/nord point bas on poursuit avec le
dossier allemand a finalement il ne
partira pas 24 heures après avoir menacé
de démissionner le ministre allemand de
l'intérieur a obtenu ce qu'il voulait
dingue et la merkel pour rester au
gouvernement la chancelière allemande
renonce à sa politique migratoire
généreux sous la pression de son aile
droite on regarde on réagit juste après
[Musique]
si la fin d'un bras de fer de plusieurs
semaines entre d'un côté anglais la
merkel chancelière allemande partisans
d'une politique migratoire d'accueil et
de l'autre côté son ministre de
l'intérieur
horst seehofer le patron de la csu
alliée bavaroise de la cdu ou le parti
de la chancelière
un ministre frondeur il menaçait de
démissionner si la chancelière ne
renoncez pas à sa politique migratoire
généreuse nous avons trouvé un accord
clair pour empêcher dans le futur
l'immigration clandestine aux frontières
entre l'allemagne et l'autriche
cet accord solide qui correspond à mes
idées me permet de rester ministre
fédéral de l'intérieur des travaux
publics et de la patrie le compromis
trouvé prévoit qu'à l'avenir les
demandeurs d'asile arrivant en allemagne
mais déjà enregistrés dans d'autres pays
de l'union soient conduits dans des
centres de transit directement à la
frontière et non plus répartis dans des
foyers dans l'ensemble du pays
avec cet accord nous conservons l'esprit
du partenariat européen et en même temps
nous avons une solution pour organiser
et minimiser la migration secondaire
c'est ce qu'ils étaient et restent
importants pour moi c'est pourquoi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui après des
discussions difficiles nous avons trouvé
un bon accord accord conclu merkel sauve
son gouvernement
mais l'accord est déjà critiquée c'est
l'effet domino tant redouté l'autriche
voisine annonce à son tour vouloir
contrôler sa frontière pour éviter
l'arrivée des migrants en provenance
d'allemagne ou d'italie
et voilà les grands principes du tout
récent sommet de bruxelles sur les
migrants remise en cause la promesse de
privilégier des solutions européennes
laissent la place aux tentations
nationale
[Musique]
voilà un gala merkel qui a trouvé un
accord lundi avec son mini de
l'intérieur instaurant des 100 de
transit à la frontière entre l'allemagne
et l'autriche c'est un durcissement très
net de la politique migratoire de
l'allemagne sylvie guillaume c'est un
changement de pratique oui effectivement
en même temps ce qui est imaginé
maintenant ressemble fort aux zones
d'attentes telles qu'elles existent
d'ailleurs moi ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est d'abord quelle est la
frontière avec le refoulement qui est
interdit par toutes les pratiques
internationales et européennes
et deuxièmement quel est l'effet induit
quel est l'effet dominos sur tout ça
parce que là il ya un tri qui s'effectue
si les gens n'entrent pas en allemagne
pour des raisons x ou y
ils sont refoulés ils sont refoulés en
autriche de tri je viens de dire que
finalement dans ces conditions elle
ferme elle même ses frontières et donc
retour à l'envoyeur
c'est à dire en italie qui elle même
n'est pas tout à fait prête non plus à
ouvrir ses frontières dans ce livre la
gueule c'est la fin de la libre
circulation des personnes non seulement
un risque très fort parce que on
rétablit des contrôles et des frontières
intérieures
mais c'est surtout qu'on ne résout pas
sur le fond cette situation en renvoyant
à l'autre la responsabilité de la
gestion des personnes ce qui n'est pas
acceptable
yannick jadot sur l'effet domino
l'autriche qui réagit aussitôt elle veut
prendre des mesures pour protéger ses
frontières sud
c'est à dire celle qu'elle partage avec
l'italie l'idée que politiquement pour
régler un problème on reprend les
arguments et les solutions de l'extrême
droite c'est évidemment plongé l'europe
dans le chaos c'est plonger l'europe
dans les égoïsmes et surtout ça ne
résout rien parce que comme
effectivement sylvinho le dire c'est
renvoyé aux autres la responsabilité
d'agir
la seule façon qu'on peut avoir de gérer
cette question des réfugiés
c'est de s'y mettre ensemble de la même
façon
vis-à-vis de poutine vis-à-vis trump sur
notre politique industrielle sur le
dérèglement climatique sur la question
du chômage et notamment du chômage de
notre jeunesse c'est ensemble qu'on y
arrivera et que à chaque fois s'il ya du
chantage dans les coalitions qui est de
dire je vais essayer y compris ça marche
pas là c'est sous en bavière est en
train de perdre des voix
biz
vis de l'extrême droite donc reprendre
le discours de l'extrême droite c'est
toujours aller vers l'original et
surtout ça ne résout rien
c'est un échec complet et ça ne résout
rien nicolas belge je suppose que ce
durcissement de la politique migratoire
de l'allemagne où le saluer c'est une
nécessité absolue et c'est une nécessité
qui s'exprime dans toutes les nations
d'europe aujourd'hui j'entends le
discours de yannick jadot mais c'est
d'illusions toujours des solutions à 28
en réalité on voit qu'aujourd'hui les
solutions nationales c'est des
coopérations européennes sepa sepa
l'encontre de l'esprit européen mais ça
va à l'encontre de la commission
européenne de la logique de
l'intégration et des solutions qui
aident nécessiterait absolument une
harmonisation à l'échelle européenne non
aujourd'hui on voit des solutions
nationales
on voit que les frontières extérieures
n'ont jamais été protégée on sent déjà
mais donner les moyens le résultat est
bien c'est que le chancelier d'autriche
sébastienne coeur ce qui prend la
présidence du conseil
à partir du 1er juillet dit bah tant que
les frontières extérieures ne sont pas
protégés on va établir des des
frontières nationales et ce qui a sauvé
angela merkel est obligé de céder
finalement à
seehofer qui lui disait la même chose
disait il faut protéger nos frontières
nationales parce qu'on est face à une
immigration massive totalement
incontrôlée totalement anarchique et
puisqu'il n'ya pas il n'a aucune volonté
à l'échelle européenne de freiner
l'immigration au contraire il faut bien
dire que ça fait des années que l'union
européenne encourage les flux
migratoires aussi bien les goûts c'est
bien c'est que l'état gère les sites de
vidéos voulait réagir pour être conforme
aux aspirations de leurs parce que je
pense qu'il ya une autre
il ya une autre façon de voir les choses
monsieur bedie à 28 ça marche pas il
faut faire entre nous moi j'ai une autre
solution enfin un doctorat en tout cas
une autre idée à mettre sur le tapis
pourquoi ne pas considérer que vit ce
grade
ils ont dit qu'ils n'en voulaient pas à
la limite il pourrait être pénalisé pour
ne pas accueillir ok mais on forge
quelque chose de solidaires à
quelques-uns une sorte de coopération
avec des pays qui sont concernés et qui
essaye de trouver des solutions ensemble
donc on n'est pas sur 28 parce qu'on
sait qu'on n'y arrivera pas normal on
est mal précisément avec monsieur b avec
son voeu concernés les litanies ce que
vous dans quelques savez vous devez la
coopération qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce
week-end au au sommet est-ce qu'il
n'était pas prêt à faire quelque chose
de solidaires à quelques-uns c'est la
réalité il est que ce traitement
possible de trouver des accords dans une
configuration qui n'est effectivement
pas c'est pas la solution que je
préférais mais ni configuration qui
n'est pas forcément à 28 ou à 27 pour
essayer de trouver des solutions à
quelques-uns faisons ça mettons ça sur
la table
je voulais que vous réagissiez vous 3 ce
sondage six français sur dix estiment
que la france accueille trop de migrants
a selon un dernier sondage est ce que
vous êtes surpris par ce sondage mais
qu'est ce qu'il dit selon vous qu'est ce
qu'il dit il dit que les responsables
politiques servent un discours quand le
ministre qu l'on parle de submersion de
l'immigration il participe d'un
sentiment qu effectivement la question
des migrations n'est pas maîtrisé mais
pas contrôler il favorise un sentiment
qu'il y aille
l'impuissance publique à gérer ces
questions là il favorise l'inquiétude
la question n'est pas de faire des
leçons de morale aux françaises et aux
français
en france on a inventé les french
doctors en france il ya toujours de la
solidarité
mais quand on dit la vérité quand on
fait de la pédagogie et qu'on agit en
responsabilité sur la question de
l'aquarius franchement le président de
la république se serait adressé aux
français en disant vous avez 629
personnes des femmes des enfants des
hommes qui sont des survivants et nous
allons participer à cet effort de
solidarité
si l'union européenne se donner les
moyens d'aider les collectivités locales
les familles les associations qui aident
les réfugiés tout ça se passerait
beaucoup mieux parce qu'on donnerait une
image de nous déjà bien meilleur
nicolas voulait réagir aux moissons
d'âge pour soir hier d'entendre la
gauche qui parle toujours de sentiments
pour masquer la réalité il ya quelques
années on nous parlait de sentiment
d'insécurité alors que la france
subissait une hausse spectaculaire de la
délinquance et de la criminalité là
c'est pareil on parle de 200 langues la
submersion la réalité elle est simple
c'est les chiffres
la france reçoit environ 450 milles
personnes par an cette fois 262000 mère
amante et pas n'importe quoi 262 me
raconter une vitre de saint geours c'est
262000 type de séjour auxquels
s'ajoutent 100 milles 102 milles pour
être précis demande d'adhésion
s'ajoutent à ces criminels
d'accord les diplômés français l'idée
vous est consommée qui quitte la france
savent provoqua préjudice à l'assaut du
werder dégration maniement incontrôlée
eh bien elle subit et chez un autre
préjudice à la france de posséder deux
côtés valls avait calé les voilà on a vu
qu'elle est la part de mes impôts pour
deux médecins non français dans toute
une série de zones rurales
après on est formé suffisamment de
médecins en l'avenir de leonardo y
compris en matière on augmente le nombre
de médecins corps de dix ans voilà dix
ans à san mamés payant donc la mal aimée
des notions n'émettrons pas non en
quelques années en forme ascendante ces
dernières questions et vérité si on
arrive à la fin de cette émission
dernière question est ce que vous
craignez une poussée populiste lors des
élections européennes 2019
posez lui la question bien sûr bien sûr
qu'il faut le craindre à partir du
moment où l'europe je les dis et les
notamment les dirigeants parce qu'on n'a
pas de politique migratoire européenne
la réalité c'est qu'on n'a pas de
politique migratoire open à partir du
moment où nos dirigeants mettent la tête
dans le sable renvoient la
responsabilité aux autres
instrumentalise la question des migrants
à des fins de politique nationale à
partir du moment où l'europe n'investit
pas dans sa jeunesse sur des beaux
projets effectivement les populistes
gagnerons et vous savez après le break
site
on a dit plus jamais ça plus jamais
comme avant aujourd'hui tout le monde
regarde avec un petit sourire ironique
les difficultés de match 2 2 me theresa
may eh ben c'est une erreur parce que la
réalité c'est que l'italie est passée à
l'extrême droite
donc prenons nos responsabilités et
poussons nos dirigeants à être à la
hauteur des enjeux
c'est ce que fait en partie de parlement
européen c'est qu'on attend de nos
dirigeants actuellement vous allez
aborder comment ces élections
européennes avec vos partis respectifs
chez vidéo en date en sorte qu'ils ne se
soient pas de la prophétie
auto-réalisatrice qu'on montre pas ce
qui va se passer mais qu'on agisse sur
ce qui va se passer moi j'agirai pour
que les choses soient différentes de ce
qui est annoncé aux élections
européennes y aura deux lignes qui
s'affronteront il y aura pas de place
pour les ambiguïtés il y aura d'un côté
la ligne d'emmanuel macron qui portera
un projet de fédéralisme marche forcé il
le fera avec angela merkel
ce sera toujours
d'immigration toujours plus de traité de
libre-échange toujours plus de
concurrence déloyale
et puis il y aura le projet alternatif
que nous nous défendrons d'une europe
des nations lors des protections en
europe des coopérations
je crois que et sanaryenne populiste
enfin je sais pas ce qu'on appelle
populisme ambiant conclut il y ait de la
fin de l'europe du sud vidéo moi ça me
va bien ça ne dérange pas mais ça révèle
ce terme de populiste révèle
fondamentalement le mépris que beaucoup
ont à l'égard du peuple donnera
rendez-vous donc on mai 2019 pour ces
élections européennes c'est la fin
d'europe hebdo merci à vous trois d'être
venus débattre c'était très constructif
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi un
c'était le dernier repère dos de la
saison se retrouve bien sûr à la rentrée
en septembre et 2019 année européenne en
perspective d'ici là passez de très
belles vacances pour ceux qui ont la
chance d'en avoir
elle rester avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires bye
[Musique]